vous et les cauchemars pierre ah bah oui
ça vous arrive souvent
oui oui ça va vous arriver ce soir merde
infâme intel ou cauchemar tiens vous
ressembler à quoi dans vos cauchemars je
suis à l'école et le prof me dit c'est
lorsque vous êtes célèbre qu'il faut pas
faire vos devoirs et je me réveille en
sueur sans avoir fait leurs valises à
man c'est qui votre femme dans vos
cauchemars
ma mère à lovren prison l'accusé dans
votre cauchemar ceux qui comme moi oui
franchement je serais pas quoi vous de
la france excepté qu'elle filme dans vos
cauchemars
un film de cul parce que j'ai
voilà on vous fait quoi comme critique
dans vos cauchemars
ok maintenant c'est que je mets un homme
est pire cauchemar vous vivez au caire
dans vos cauchemars ou dans des endroits
d'un cauchemar une île déserte où un
petit village
enfin là où il n'y a pas beaucoup de
monde mais pas de bars de nuit et tout
s'arrête je fais pas que ça vous écoutez
quoi comme musique dans le cauchemar du
rap mais pas seulement
enfin du rap et de la house va seulement
dans mes cauchemars dans les mauls unis
où je veux aussi quoi vous avez peur de
quoi dans vos cauchemars pierre g j'ai
peur qu'on me pardonne pas et mes
erreurs
ouais vous m'aurez commandant vos
cauchemars le jour j'ai rêvé que je
mourrais comment elle assène le noyer
dichter d'une voiture et je vous voyez
mais revêt la voiture était dans un lac
léman train de conduire est monté on
découvre fois sur vous dans vos
cauchemars je suis un mauvais coup vous
fait attaquer par quel animal dans vos
cauchemars pierre o
je suis fatigué jours par une loi non
c'est terrible pour vous faites chargé
par une loi c'est cesser mauvaise
journée à la campagne ou non mais c'est
vrai en même temps les oies c'est un
avantage c'est que c'est le meilleur
chien de garde loi oui et puis on peut
la bouche et après il nous fait trop
vous pensez que cette interview n'est
qu'un cauchemar qui va bientôt s'arrêter
pierre tuvéri à cette adresse